THUNDER PARLEY: I'm Thunder
Parley, senior software
engineer at Google+ for
businesses and schools.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: And I'm Joel
Kalmanowicz, product manager
for the same.
We're here today to talk to you
about Google+'s additional
features for businesses and
schools, and to help you apply
Google+ in your organizations.
Let's take a quick look
at what we're
going to cover today.
First, we're going to provide
some context on why this is
important to us and to our
business partners.
We'll take a quick look through
of the headline
enterprise features
we provide today.
THUNDER PARLEY: And then, I'll
take us on a quick dive into
our most important safeguard
for sharing in the domain.
Then, we'll give you a quick
preview of something we've
been working on for you
developers out there.
And then, we'll wrap it up and
save some time for a brief
question and answer session
at the end.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: All
right, let's get
familiar with the field.
Social is the next generation.
And with Google+, you can
connect to your local offices,
global teammates, and external
partners and clients.
People want more information,
not more emails.
You can share with anything,
with anyone.
But that doesn't mean
you should share
everything with everyone.
Google+ provides a framework
to try and help your users
make the right decisions
regarding what to share with
whom in the right context,
internally and externally, to
work smarter, faster,
and better.
THUNDER PARLEY: And we want it
to be easy to find the people
you need to reach and to keep
your communication safe and
within your company's domain
when necessary.
And to this end, we're working
to enhance Google+ to make
this awesome social tool even
better for your organizations.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: We're already
getting some positive
feedback about this.
Brady Corporation has found that
they've been able to help
their distributed offices come
together using Google+.
Fairfax Media has used Google+
sharing and docs to facilitate
overcoming geographical
barriers themselves.
And The Grommet has also used
Google+ and Hangouts, which
they like so much they've even
managed to completely replace
their wired phone infrastructure
with it.
So they use Google+ as their
primary means of communication
within the company.
Now, let's take a look at some
of the features we've been
releasing lately to
facilitate this.
Domain labels are something that
we released recently to
try and address the need to make
sure that you're sharing
in the right context with
the right audiences.
So I'll walk you through
an example.
Let's say that I worked for
a company called Ink 42.
If you have a look at my
profile, you'll see the
ink-42.com domain label there,
which indicates that I'm a
member of this domain.
But you can only see this label
if you are also logged
in as a member of
the same domain.
So it's an internally visible
tool to help you differentiate
between people who are inside
your domain and out.
So if I'm logged in, I look
at my own profile.
I can see this.
And it reaffirms to me, oh
yeah, I'm not using my
personal profile.
I can also look at a co-worker
and see that, hey, on the
hover card here, Allison is also
a member of my domain.
So if I interact with her, I
can rest assured that I'm
interacting within
my organization.
And in this case, I don't even
have to click through to her
profile to see this.
It's right there on the hover
card that pops up when you
mouse over her profile
picture or name.
Now, our goal in calling
this out is to, again,
differentiate between the
various profiles a person can
have to help you share
in the right context.
This is especially important
when, for example, let's say
Allison has her work profile,
which is in the same
to domain as me.
But she has a personal profile
down there at the bottom.
So when I'm trying to + mention
her here, and I see
that, oh, there are multiple
profiles here.
Am I trying to share with her
personal profile, with her
work profile?
This lets me make the
right decision.
And in this case, if I want
to share it within my
organization, I look for
the domain label.
We've started surfacing this
in the key areas which we
think are the most impactful--
hover card, back here, profile,
and then again in
auto-complete.
And we're looking at introducing
this in more
locations in the future.
THUNDER PARLEY: So we also
challenged the Hangouts
engineering team to really
pump up the experience.
We understand that businesses
and schools typically have a
need for more concurrent
collaboration, whether it be
closing a global sales deal,
an after-hours tutoring
session, a big research project,
interviewing people
from around the world.
So we've boosted the number of
participants by a whopping 50%
to 15 live streams.
That means all 15 participants
can use all the existing
collaboration tools, such as
working on the drive document
together, in real time.
And when you start a business
Hangout, we make it easy to
only invite your coworkers
if you want to
have a company meeting.
And if anyone external tries to
get in, [CLAPS], it's not
happening unless you've
invited them in.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ:
That's right.
And then, we get back to the
original and the most
important differentiator for
businesses and schools.
THUNDER PARLEY: The ability to
create restricted posts.
When you restrict a post,
it stays within
your Google Apps domain.
Unlike a normal consumer post,
the audience is strictly
capped to your domain members.
So you cannot even re-share or +
mention a post to show it to
people outside your domain.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: The admin has
a default option for this.
When they go into their control
panel, you can see
that they can choose to make the
default for all new posts
within the domain restricted
to that domain.
This means that if the user
doesn't make any additional
actions or doesn't really think
about what they're doing
and they're a member of your
domain, their posts will be
safeguarded and restricted
to their domain.
It requires an explicit action,
with a conscious
decision, to change this at post
write time, so that you
create an unrestricted
post instead.
If we go back here, you can see
at the bottom right, the
Allow External Sharing button.
That's in this pop-up here.
Once they click that, the
restriction is removed.
And they can share this post
outside the domain.
THUNDER PARLEY: All right, so
let me give you a little bit
more detail on exactly
how this works.
So hold on to your hats.
We're going to have some fun
with some basic Venn diagrams.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ:
You all remember
your set theory, right?
THUNDER PARLEY: Well, I don't
like to call it "theory,"
because I'm going to show you
how it actually works.
So I'll call it "set
practice."
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: All
right, Thunder.
THUNDER PARLEY: So this circle
here represents the collection
of profiles in your circles.
These are all the profiles that
you've added inside or
outside of your domain.
Now, this square here represents
the collection of
profiles that are strictly in
your Google Apps domain.
So let's say you share a post
with people in your circles.
Now, if it's a restricted post,
this green box limits
the audience.
This post will be shared and
visible to people only in the
intersection here.
Now, this works the same
with any specific
circles you might use.
So let's say you want to share
with your buddies at work.
I work with Joel.
I'm going to share
a post with him.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ:
Thanks, Thunder.
I take a look at this post.
And I decide, hey,
you know what?
This is probably the best cat
video I've seen all day.
I want to share it with
my friends, too.
So because it's a restricted
post, when I try and do this,
only those friends of mine who
are within the domain get to
see this re-shared post.
So while the audience for the
post has expanded by virtue of
my re-sharing it, it's only
expanded within that green box
of people who are within
our Google Apps domain.
Now, it may all be fun and
games, a little bit facetious
with cat videos.
But let's say that instead of
re-sharing that, I re-shared
some internal information
about my company's
confidential plans to build
a better mousetrap.
In this case, no matter what
the mousetrap is, I'd be
pretty glad that by re-sharing
it to my friends, even by
accident, it's still kept within
the domain and no one
who's outside of the
domain gets that.
If I tried to re-share with
journalists circle, for
example, and none of those
journalists were members of my
own domain, none of
them would see it.
THUNDER PARLEY: So you see, your
choice of circles and the
people you share a post
with is a union.
But if the post is restricted,
then that list is intersected
with the domain members to
calculate the final audience
allowed to view the post.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: And the same
thing applies with [? + ?]
mentions.
Let's take a look.
Here, we're looking
at another domain.
This time, it's altostrat.com.
You can see that this post was
restricted to the domain by
the building icon, which is
just beneath Eddy, in Eddy
Johnston, which is the
author of the post.
Someone has decided that, hey,
they're going to try to
[? + ?] mention one
of my profiles.
But as we talked about earlier,
my profile in this
case is in the ink-42 domain,
or maybe even
in the Google domain.
So the lack of a domain label
there indicates that I'm not
in the altostrat domain because
we're looking at this
from the perspective of
someone in altostrat.
So even though there's no domain
label there, it's the
end of the day.
We're all feeling
a bit fatigued.
Let's say they try and
+ mention me anyway.
+ mention fails.
You get a little warning
reminding you that, hey,
people outside your organization
can't get to see
restricted content because it's
safeguarded against that.
THUNDER PARLEY: And now, we
know, hey, that's some fancy
JavaScript.
And for you web developers out
there who like to mess around
with our JSON and try and trick
our servers, we keep it
safely tucked away in the back
end, that once a post has been
created restricted, we continue
to enforce that
restriction on every activity,
even on the re-shares.
We look up the original
restriction, and we know that
that restriction must
continue to stay.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ:
That's right.
Now, we've taken a good look at
the features we've already
released, maybe a little boring
for those of you who
are pretty familiar with it.
So we know why you're
really here, right?
THUNDER PARLEY: The amazing
after party?
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: That, too.
THUNDER PARLEY: The chance to
meet the Conductor in person?
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: Or maybe
to share a cold
one with you, Thunder?
If you don't get that, watch
"The Internship" trailer.
THUNDER PARLEY: Oh,
that's right.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: But really,
we want to know what's new.
So today--
THUNDER PARLEY: We are
pleased to announce
our development of--
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: The
Google+ Domains API.
This API allows you, as app
developers, to work within a
Google Apps domain and, say
you're developing in-house.
You can develop an API call
in your application that
integrates your Google Apps
domain with third-party tools.
You can also work as a software
vendor developing
application for other businesses
to install for
their own Google Apps domains.
And we're still in
development.
But Thunder has whipped
something up for you to show
you a little demo.
THUNDER PARLEY: So this part of
the demo was pre-recorded
earlier for robustness against
lack of connectivity.
But we'll be including a link
to the recording on YouTube
for people browsing
the slides later.
For now, we'll just play
the video directly.
So those of you watching later,
on YouTube, you'll be
looking at the recorded
recording demo.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: We
must go deeper.
THUNDER PARLEY: And
deeper we shall.
Let's begin.
So here, we have Kavita Singh.
She's a manager of a small sales
team and is logged into
her CRM app.
She sees green.
Green's good.
Brigitta has already exceeded
her monthly quota by 12%.
There's a button generated by
the app that will quickly
allow her to click and
congratulate Brigitta.
A quick click makes an Ajax
call to a simple servlet--
I'll show you the code
in a minute--
which uses the Google domains
API to create a new post.
We call this an activity.
Share it to Brigitta and
the rest of her domain.
That button linked
to the post.
And now, we're looking
at the post.
And we can see that this post
was indeed created and
restricted to the Google
Apps domain of Ink 42.
And it cannot be shared
outside of the domain.
So now, we've created
this post.
Let's cut over to Brigitta who--
she's working away in
her inbox, closing sales deals,
helping partners, financing.
She didn't get to be the best
on the team by just sitting
around doing nothing all day.
And this notification's
rolled in.
And she sees that her manager
has congratulated her.
And Joel has already
+1ed the post.
That puts a little smile
on her face.
So she's going to leave a little
comment back to her
manager thanking her and
reminding her that she has
worked extra hard this month.
And she's going to take some
time off in Maui at the end of
the month, which I
personally love.
And if you've been there, I
don't know how you can't.
So that's not the end of our
story there, though.
She's going to go back, keep
working on her inbox.
She's finishing up her plan to
help customers finance and
further drive sales.
She's about wrapped that up.
And now, another notification's
come in.
Oh, something from Joel.
Well, Joel's a newer employee
at the company.
And from this, he can see well,
Brigitta is the team
leader in sales right now.
And he mentions Mike and
asks for her advice.
Well, later, she will go
on to mentor Joel.
And they're growing the team
to make them a lot better.
So just in this simple demo,
we see that with the Google
Domains API, you're not just
creating content so people
have something to read
in your domain.
You can help spread
information.
You can boost morale.
You can reinforce
communications
between team members.
And you can help grow
productivity in your
organization.
So now, let's go over to
the code snippets.
I'm going to just show you the
very simple way it was to
write a quick Java servlet
to call the API.
Here, you have your basic
servlet set up.
The message and the email
address of the person we want
to congratulate, some
boilerplate code to do the
OAuth2 dance and get
the credentials for
the logged in user.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: Let's
take a look now.
How do you actually create
the activity?
So to create and populate the
activity, it's rather
straightforward.
Using the library that comes
with the Google domains API,
we create a new activity,
which is what
we also call a post.
This + object, we set the
original content, that's the
body of the message that
you want to send.
And we set the ACL on it, which
is who we want to be
able to see this post.
In another example, you could
have maybe just congratulated
Brigitta privately.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: Then, you
wouldn't have had that setType
domain entry in the
immutable list.
THUNDER PARLEY: Exactly.
So in this case, we add
two ACL entries.
The first one is domain.
And this allows anyone
in ink-42.com to be
able to see the post.
The second entry we add, we add
this person type by email.
In this case, this was
Brigitta's email.
Now, she's in the domain.
We don't strictly need
to add this.
But because we've added her
explicitly, our systems will
generate that notification.
And that's why you saw the
notification pop up directly
to Brigitta.
And then finally, we say that
for this object, we want it to
be restricted to True.
This is required right now
for the domains API.
Setting this to True is what
tells our system that, yes, I
want the domain restriction on
this activity, this post I'm
creating, so it can only be
visible in my domain and not
be re-shared outside of it.
Now that we've created the
activity, it's as simple as
calling the plus activities
insert and executing it, which
will make the call to the HGP
API and create the post.
The response back from that
was the activity.
And in the example I did, I
simply just wrote the URL back
to the call.
And that's why the button to
congratulate Brigitta then
turned to a link directly
to the post.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ:
That's right.
So once the activity
is created, you
don't simply lose it.
You can actually find it again
quite easily by requesting the
URL from it.
THUNDER PARLEY: And I would just
like to reinforce that
with the domains API right now,
all posts created are to
be restricted to the domain.
So as you experiment with this,
maybe try integrating it
with internal systems, your
own CRM apps, you can feel
safe that the activities being
created will be locked down to
your domain.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ:
That's right.
We do have a few safeguards with
this API, which is why it
is a domain specific API
for organizations.
These boil down to
two main things.
One, you have to have a
Google Apps domain.
That's the whole point
of the API.
It's the domains API.
So if you try to call the API,
and you don't have credentials
belonging to a Google Apps
domain on your account, it
won't work.
Second, you can only use
it for your own domain.
So we really mean it when we say
that you can write posts.
That's great.
All your users, you
can install apps.
You can start flooding all
your streams with useful,
engaging content.
But only your streams,
your domain.
So if you install an app within
your organization,
you've installed that app for
that organization only.
This has two immediate
effects.
First, as Thunder said, posts
are restricted to the domain,
which means that anyone in the
domain can see them, or you
can set the ACLs so that
maybe I only share
privately with Thunder.
But either way, it cannot be
re-shared outside the domain,
as we went through with the
nice, little Venn diagram.
Secondly, you can read posts
from anyone in the domain.
The great thing is you can
read these post whether
they're restricted or not.
So if I'm working in my
capacity as my Ink 42
salesperson, and I share a post
out to all of you guys,
the API can read that post
because I'm the one who wrote
it, and I'm in the domain.
THUNDER PARLEY: And so this
is just the start.
Obviously, we've started
with posts.
We intend to expand this API.
Some of you might already be
thinking, what about circles?
That's next on the radar.
We'll be adding further calls
that you can use to enhance
the Google+ experience for
Google Apps users.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: All
right, let's recap.
We've taken you through some of
the headline features that
we've released so far today.
You can see here, the domain
labels, Hangouts integrations,
restricted posts, and
the defaults that
the admin can set.
We've also, then--
THUNDER PARLEY: Had a preview
look at the new Google+
Domains API.
We took a look at the demo I
hacked up myself to showcase
how to integrate Google+ with,
say, a third-party CRM
business tool.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: So finally,
we'd like to involve you guys.
We'd love to hear
back from you.
We'd love to hear your feedback
on what you want to
do with this API.
Where should we be focusing
our efforts?
What do you want
us to work on?
Do you want us to get more
circles things going on here?
Maybe more posts, read, write,
fetch, all this stuff?
We want to hear from you.
You can fill out this form,
which, if you like, you can
write down.
But these slides will be
available later, and that is a
clickable link.
You can also talk directly to
your account managers because
if you have a Google Apps
domain, and you need to to use
this API, the account managers
will be able to help you.
And remember, you can also, if
you're purchasing or licensing
software from a vendor, you can
ask them, hey, why don't
you build an integration with
the Google+ Domains API?
So if you're using a third-party
CRM software and
you want them to integrate the
Google+ stream for your
domain, just send them a note
and say, I heard about this
Domains API at I/O.
THUNDER PARLEY: All right,
Joel, that's great.
I think that's all we really
have to announce
and go over for today.
But we're ready to take some
questions about the session.
And remember to rate the
session, as well, and then
everybody should get ready for
the after hours party.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ:
That's right.
We did want to end a little bit
early to let you guys go.
It is the end of the day.
Please step up to the mic so
we can hear you and so the
recording does catch your
question as well.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
In our organization, business
use of Google+ has
been kind of slow.
And maybe this is an
outdated mindset.
But I did see that you
had a work account
and a personal account.
Our understanding was that it
was a policy of Google not to
have multiple accounts.
So a lot of people won't get a
work account because they have
a personal one.
Is that a misunderstanding
of the policy?
Is there any way we're going to
merge, like have a way for
a single Google+ account to have
multiple email addresses
attached to it, with technical
ways of solving that problem?
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: Sure.
It sounds like you're
questioning the identity
problem here, which is
essentially that you're not
the same person to everyone
you're talking to.
I'm standing here right now,
today, in my capacity as a
Google employee.
That's not the same as me
walking down the street
tonight, where I'm just
not another person.
And so my work account at
Google, or in the example, at
Ink 42, is designed to be an
interaction with other
co-workers.
Or when I'm talking to you guys
right now, with external
parties to my company,
but still in my
capacity as an employee.
This is a very clear
differentiator between my
capacity as an individual.
So we'd like to keep these
lines separate.
And this is inherent
to approach.
THUNDER PARLEY: And regarding
the policy side of the
question, I'd refer you to talk
to the press team for the
official answer.
But when you are paying and have
these premier accounts or
for your EDU, we don't have a
problem with you obviously
using it, Google+.
We don't want you creating a
bazillion accounts out in
consumer space for your users.
Having the domains account
allows you this extra
functionality.
Regarding merging into
one profile, we
have nothing to announce.
As far as that goes right now,
you can imagine there's many
issues that complicate that,
both policy-wise and whatnot.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
THUNDER PARLEY: You're
welcome.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for releasing
the domain API.
You're very welcome.
So I work for Genentech.
And we actually have two domains
in production, one for
gene.com, and one
is roche.com.
And we are trying to pilot
users from both domains.
And this is great that we can
actually share posts from
custom web apps to our
Google+ circles.
My question is, will you add
support to actually trust
domains or have a post be shared
to multiple domains
through the API?
THUNDER PARLEY: That is a
feature we've been asked about
several times.
Again, unfortunately, we have
nothing to announce in that
space at this time.
But we have noted
that feedback.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And quick follow up.
Can you actually manage circles
using this API?
Is there a way to actually sync,
LDAP, or AD groups with
circle creation?
THUNDER PARLEY: So that's the
exciting part I hinted at.
Normally, we won't pre-announce
things.
But we have--
the circles functionality is
coming very, very soon.
Me personally, if I was say a
manager, I would love to have
the ability to say, I have
a reportees circle that
auto-updates, interns get hired,
employees transfer.
I don't have to worry
about it.
I have a reportees circle
I can share to.
AUDIENCE: So thank you.
That's fantastic.
THUNDER PARLEY: I'm glad
you're so excited.
Thank you.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ:
On this side?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Marcio.
I work for CING.
We're a software developer.
And we are super excited
about those features.
We are actually using--
I noticed the guy said
that they are not
adopting Google+ so much.
We are adopting so much
that we're using a lot
less emails, right?
But what strikes me is the fact
that no one mentioned
anything about the
communities yet.
And we love communities.
We are creating--
we have communities with more
than 1,000 members.
And we are using actively, every
day, and we would love
to see the Google+ API allowing
us to do more stuff
with the communities.
For instance, we cannot make
sure that every employee we
can only approve participation
of the domain members, right?
So it's very hard for us today
to go in a 1,000 member
community and see if there's
anyone using the personal
profile there.
And that really puts us in a
fragile situation because we
might be sharing with someone
that later can be fired.
And that person will keep
that information, right?
And another, just as a
piece of feedback--
so my question is, what are the
plans around communities?
And just as a piece of feedback,
the hover thing for
you to see the label
is not efficient.
Because if I have to approve
like 15 people, I have two
each one of them in order
to approve them, right?
So wouldn't it be better just
to see a label there?
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: Yeah.
Thank you very much.
So as we mentioned back then,
we actually are looking at
additional places we do want
to introduce those labels.
The hover card, we found very
useful simply because it is
useful on a case by case basis
when you want to know, who is
this person?
I want to learn more
about them.
But as you say, it doesn't
scale very well to
long lists of people.
So for example, search results
are something we're taking a
look at to see if maybe
it'll work out there.
THUNDER PARLEY: And
as far as what you
mentioned, you're right.
That is a very difficult
process.
And--
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: For
communities, it's a very new
feature, even in the
consumer space.
And we've been exploring with
the communities team to see
what we can do for enterprise.
So thank you very much.
THUNDER PARLEY: Feedback's
well noted.
And like we said, we're working
to make Google+ much
better for your organizations.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: Thank you.
THUNDER PARLEY: Next question.
AUDIENCE: Yes, good afternoon.
My name is [? Ringley ?]
with a 4G operator
in Malaysia.
That's the video you
saw, that's our
project with Google.
Anyway, we are super excited
about this domain concept.
Now, granted, whether it's in
school or in businesses,
people tend to share
documents.
So how would this notion of
domain be recognizable by
drive so that when you actually
want to share a
document on drive via your
Google+ circle or Google+
domain, that same domain concept
would also apply to
enforce the policies and
the access control
for objects on drive?
THUNDER PARLEY: So I think what
you're asking is, if you
were to share a document, you
want the audience of the
document to stay in
sync with the post
that it's linked with--
AUDIENCE: And constricted to
the domain, let's say.
THUNDER PARLEY: And restricted
to the domain.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: So we do
currently have domain
restrictions in documents
and we have domain
restrictions in posts.
These are two separate systems,
in some sense, as far
as that one is a social sharing
model and one of them
is a collaborative working
sharing model.
However, this whole session has
been about collaborative,
working, social sharing.
So essentially, our answer
to that is it's
interesting to hear.
It sounds like you're requesting
that these two
audiences be one and the same.
And while that is an interesting
feature request,
which I'll pass on to some
people, think about it from
the perspective today.
When you share a document, you
only want to share it with a
certain number of people.
And you specify that in
the document ACL.
When you then potentially
re-share that
document in a post--
and I say re-share
here loosely.
Essentially, you're sharing it
on Google+ for the first time,
you also choose the audience.
And you can choose to restrict
that to your domain, as well.
Either way, though, any domain
restrictions will be in effect.
So if someone, say, if Thunder
tries to share a restricted
document to me, I'm in the
domain, that's fine.
I try and re-share it on Google+
to the world at large,
they won't be able to access
it because the document
restriction is still there.
AUDIENCE: OK, all right.
That's a starting point.
We'll continue the dialogue
with you guys.
Thank you very much.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Jonathan Frankel,
School of Rock.
My question is kind of related
to some of the others.
I have a couple specific
things.
Namely, I guess feature
requests.
Will you be able to provision
the Google+ accounts?
Because right now, from what
I see is that you can allow
people to create Google+
accounts, but you can't create
it for them.
And also, it's kind of like
it's a separate thing.
The Google+ profile is separate
from your Google
account on the domain
that you have.
And again, another question.
In terms of control of data that
the Google+ profile has--
so one example is we
have people who
create Places pages.
And we kind of don't have any
control over that, which is
kind of bad for our
company stores.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: When you say
you don't have control, could
you be a little bit
more specific?
AUDIENCE: The user account
owns the Places page.
So as an admin, I can't
take it back when
they leave the company.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: Right.
At the moment, + pages are
not domain + pages.
These are consumer space
pages which are
owned by domain members.
We are looking into this.
We're actively in discussion
with the pages team to see
what we can do about this.
THUNDER PARLEY: And there's a
way to contest if you feel you
should own a page that's your
brand or identity were you can
file to reclaim the
ownership of that.
As the other one, as far as
auto-provisioning, right now
that's just a current policy
because these are--
even though they're owned by the
domain, this is a publicly
visible name and photo that is
created by the employee.
So as of today, our policy is to
leave it an employee action
to actually sign up and create
the Google+ account.
Whether or not that could change
in the future, we have
nothing to announce
at this time.
AUDIENCE: I guess that begs the
question, would you allow
for Google+ to become
a private social
network for the domain?
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: That has never
been our goal as far as
we want to be able to allow
people to interact privately.
In the same way as after this
session, any of you can kind
of come up and talk to us in a
one on one conversation, or we
could walk into a room where all
the walls are soundproof.
That's fine.
But we don't want to lock
people in that room.
We want to give them
the opportunity.
But we want to also say, if you
want to share with people
outside your domain, you want
to interact with people
outside your domain, you can.
Just be aware that you're
doing that.
And that's what all our warnings
and click through
explicit actions are
for, specifically.
THUNDER PARLEY: Yeah, it's not
just content creation.
It's also content consumption
and how you interact with the
world around you.
So it's not our goal right now
to actually limit the flows of
information beyond where
people want it to go.
They could find alternative
means.
Otherwise, what we'd want for
them to do is to be able to
make easy, smart choices
and really share
with the right people.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: And just a
quick little analogy on that.
Look at how you use email.
Your email client doesn't
prevent you from sending an
email to anyone outside
of your organization.
You use it responsibly.
Today, you guys have probably
seen a bunch of internal
Google email addresses.
You can email those addresses
because email is not an
internal only state, right?
We try to follow the same
sharing model in this case.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
I'm in Chile.
And we are one of the
biggest resellers of
Google Apps in the world.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: We're very
proud of that.
And also, we're a very good
advocate of Google+.
And at least the way I see
Google+ in a social side
should be based also
on mobile app.
Nevertheless, if you enable
restricted posts by default on
your Google Apps, you're
going to lose the
mobile app on your Android.
And is that going
to change soon?
Or what's the roadmap there?
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Soon?
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: Just yes.
AUDIENCE: Enough?
THUNDER PARLEY: Yes.
Not as soon as I'd
want, but yes.
Very soon.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: That was
my question.
THUNDER PARLEY: All right!
AUDIENCE: I have one
last question.
So will [? Vic ?] actually demo
the tags that you will
actually be populating tags for
posts automatically based
on some of the-- either
the image or the
data within the post?
For enterprise, there is the
Google Tag Manager that you
can use with Analytics.
Is there any plan to actually
have so enterprises can define
some tags that can be used
within a domain that can be
managed with a Google
Tag Manager that
integrates with posts?
So you can actually do searches
and analytics based
off of tags, and allow users to
populate or pick tags that
are already published or
being used frequently?
Do you know what I'm
talking about?
THUNDER PARLEY: I think
It sounds more
like a feature request.
I don't have anything to--
I'm not as familiar with
that topic area.
But we don't have anything
to announce at this time.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ:
That's right.
But please, thank you
for your feedback.
THUNDER PARLEY: And please,
please do actually send that
feedback in.
Because I might mince some
of the words if I try to
re-create it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Paul McLannes from
Fairfax Media.
You actually quoted
my CIO in your
presentation, Andrew Lamperty.
And the funny thing is we use
Google Apps for pretty much
everything now, except
we still use Yammer
as opposed to Google+.
So I was just wondering if you
think there's any features
that you think your competitors
might have that
you really want to get into
the apps, I guess, as a
product manager that maybe will
convince more people to
switch over.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: I'm sorry.
Could you summarize
the question?
AUDIENCE: Do you think there's
any features missing in + at
the moment that your
competitors, such as Yammer or
other internal networks,
might already have?
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: As a product
manager, my perspective on
this is that I don't try to
make my decisions based on
what my competitors are doing.
I try and take user feedback
about what people want, what
we can try and do for them
that's the right thing to do.
For example, I believe Thunder
doesn't even have a Facebook
page because he doesn't want to
be unduly influenced by the
state of the world today.
It's sometimes--
if you're familiar with the term
zero gravity thinking,
it's essentially trying to keep
yourself only partially
in context so that when
you do need context,
you can go get it.
But when you try and brainstorm
ideas, you're not
held back by the way everyone
else has been
thinking about it.
THUNDER PARLEY: And we
understand that our
competitors do make very
compelling products.
They offer different
feature sets.
And like Joel is saying, it's
not a race sometimes.
Sometimes they'll work
better for you.
And we're just trying to build
the best product we can.
And trust we, we're not running
out of any features
that we want to work on.
But we want to hear more
feedback about where you would
like to see Google+ go.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: Right, so as
an actionable thing from what
you said, essentially, if there
are features that you
find useful in a competitor's
product, feel free to put in a
feature request.
Let us know you want to see
something like this.
It's the users that
we listen to.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Stewart Gable from Ancoris
Enterprise, Google Apps reseller.
We've had feedback from
enterprise users of Google+
that when users leave, they're
missing the threaded comments
from within the activity
stream.
And I just wondered whether
there was any thought about a
way of preserving that?
THUNDER PARLEY: So I can tell
you that the state of it today
technically is when you go and
remove that account, you
essentially delete that account
and then all the data
gets deleted, which is why the
threaded comments are gone.
But as an admin, that
is data you own.
I think it's something--
it's a feature request
at this point.
Right now, it would
mimic the same--
essentially the same behavior
if I had a Gmail account.
And then I deleted that account,
my comments from
Google+ world would be gone.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: So we are
looking at it, though.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Just from our perspective, the
minimal kind of request would
be for an ability to export with
the threading preserved.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: Well, in that
case, this API might be
very useful to you because you
could read their posts.
AUDIENCE: That's what I
was wondering, yeah.
THUNDER PARLEY: Read
and archive
activities and comments.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ:
That's right.
If you don't want to do it
yourself, any developer out
there, feel free to make an API
to try and help with this.
Be aware that our current terms
do not deal with keeping
data that you read.
So this is something we're
looking into, as well.
We do here you.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So just to
follow up to that--
THUNDER PARLEY: I don't have a
special prize for asking the
most questions.
AUDIENCE: No, no, no, I just
have too many questions.
Sorry.
THUNDER PARLEY: That's okay.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ:
No, that's fine.
AUDIENCE: So some of the
policies for purging data of
deleted accounts, you do hold
onto Google Sites that are
created by users.
You're not purging some data.
I know Mail and Calendar data
gets purged after the user
leaves and the account
is deleted.
Why not hold the Google+
information and let the
enterprise choose whether
they want to or not
to delete that data?
Because it is, after all, the
property of the enterprise.
The individual is not
taking it with them.
The account is suspended.
It's gone.
I'm just trying to understand
your reasoning.
THUNDER PARLEY: Without
rehashing more and more and
more of the technical stuff,
we were talking about an
identity of a person who created
that content versus
something like a site other
people manage or Docs, which
we actually allow you to
transfer the ownership when an
employee leaves.
You can transfer them to their
manager, some other coworkers,
an ownership.
The idea of transferring their
personal comments and posts,
right now our system says
that goes with the user.
You get rid of the user account,
that goes away.
But like we said--
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: We're
looking at it.
THUNDER PARLEY: Feel free
to add on to it
as a feature request.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: And to be
clear here, the comments we do
hear back from you right now
do matter to us a lot.
Because as much as we can get
data as far as, OK, this many
different people are requesting
these features,
this is something a lot of
people are getting in, and we
de-duplicate these things down
to a single request with x
number of people.
It's this personal feedback we
get from you in these big
ticket events like I/O
that really do
help push the needle.
Because after all, we're not
just in it for ourselves.
We're not just a little
sub-unit of Google.
We're working with Google with
enterprise and with Docs and
Drive and many different teams
to try and make this stuff
happen for you.
So the better armed we are to
argue our point that you are
users, you are everyone's users,
and we want to do the
right thing for you, the better
we all work together.
THUNDER PARLEY: So thank you
everyone for staying through
the session.
We appreciate your questions.
[APPLAUSE]
THUNDER PARLEY: And enjoy
the rest of your I/O.